hey guys quick note my brand new book
the authoritarian moment is out
this week go pick up a copy today i
think it's really important
it's about how all of the major
institutions of american society have
now been
taken over and weaponized by the left
against dissent
it's not just about how they did it it's
about how we take those institutions
back
check out the link in the description
below and get a copy of the
authoritarian moment
the most important story that i didn't
think was going to matter but but it
does
simone biles simone biles is
apparently an olympic athlete i had
never heard of simone biles until last
night i don't watch the olympics
it's never particularly interested me
and
in the recent years where american
athletes are turning against their
country i'm not saying someone miles did
that
but where a number of athletes are doing
that i'm just not interested at all so
simone biles is apparently a very
popular and accomplished gymnast
and simone biles decided because she
performed badly in some
event that she was just going to quit
the olympics she was sent to the
olympics
to represent the united states to bring
home medals to do
sport battle against other countries
and to bring home medals for the united
states but then she just wasn't feeling
it one day
she just wasn't feeling it so in the
past when olympians have not just
injured their feelings
but injured their bodies they have still
gone on
they've still competed they've still
fought to bring home those medals for
the united states compare
as my friend charlie kirk did on the
internet yesterday compared
those good old days to simone biles
today
[Applause]
she was there for gold there for her
team for herself for her country
different variables and i think we're
just a little bit too stressed out
um but we should be out here having fun
and sometimes
that's not the case okay there's a lot
of variables as to why she quit
and it's she was a little stressed out
and look she's just there to have fun
she's just there for her right
of course not i mean this is this is sad
this is pathetic this is disgraceful
but i don't want to be too hard on
simone biles here
one cause i don't know anything about
simon biles and i'm not that interested
but but also
two because i think simone biles is the
voice of her generation i think she is
the voice of a generation that was not
not taught duty that was actually taught
to mock duty it was taught to mock
honor and the things that are higher
than one's own
pleasure and one's own comfort
simone biles as she quits the olympics
because she's got the bad feels she says
i've never felt like this going into a
competition before i tried to go out
there and have fun
and warm up in the back went a little
bit better but then once i came out here
no mental's not there so i just need to
let the girls do it and focus on myself
physically i feel good i'm in shape she
says she said this to the today show
emotionally that kind of varies in the
time and moment coming here to the
olympics and being the head star isn't
an easy feat
so we're just trying to take it one day
at a time and we'll see it's really
really pathetic and disgraceful
because she's not there to have fun and
she's not there for herself
and she's she's not there as just oopsie
daisy
think about the person whose spot she
took
think about the people who spend their
whole lives trying to make it to the
olympics
and then this gal took another gal spot
and then because she just didn't have
the right feels that day
she said no i'm not having as much fun
as i used to
ah you know you got the imagine the guys
storming normandy
say ah you know this isn't as fun as it
used to be
imagine you're at your office you've got
a very important project that has to get
done
and then one of the key guys on the team
he says ah you know what guys
it just doesn't i didn't know i'm not
enjoying it as much as i you know good
luck see ya
i'm li i'm quitting it's just it's just
quitting i know some people are trying
to defend her they say
she has mental problems maybe she does i
don't know i mean
i know some people have been blaming it
on mental problems i know a lot of
people are
blaming a lot of things on mental
problems because suffering and grievance
now
now carries social currency but if if
this woman really has mental problems
then she's
you know she should never have been
competing in the first place i mean she
needs to get the help that she needs
right
or is or is that just an excuse because
she just didn't you know she didn't feel
it
she felt she wasn't competing at her
best and maybe she just doesn't want to
and in our culture there's nothing
nothing more important than one's
will than one's appetite than one's
pleasure and comfort and desire
very sad stuff sad stuff i mean this is
part of this just
underscores my decision
not to watch or care about the olympics
at all
hey i'm glad you liked that clip i
really it
warms my heart now you get the whole
show you can get the whole show
on spotify apple podcasts google play
wherever you get your podcasts
the show is the michael knowles show the
episode is the january 6th commission
clown show
head on don't be an adam kinzinger go on
head on over there do it right now
you can also get my book speechless
controlling words controlling minds see
you next time
[Music]
[Music]